Resuelve para "x" y para "y".
"2x" menos "y" igual a 14
y por otra parte tengo "-6x" más "3y" igual a -42.
Y bueno, quiero resolver este sistema por
el método de suma y resta
o por el método de eliminación
y para eso lo que quiero hacer es eliminar a la "y".
Y para eliminar a la "y" lo que tengo que
hacer es poner un 3 aquí y por lo tanto,
para poner un 3 aquí, lo que necesito hacer
es multiplicar a esta ecuación de arriba por 3,
si yo por una parte tengo "-3y"
y después tengo más "3y" y al sumarlo,
pues estos dos se van a cancelar
y que es justo lo que yo quiero.
Por lo tanto, lo que voy a hacer es tomarme la primera ecuación y la voy a multiplicar toda entera por 3.
Entonces déjame ponerlo por acá, esto es
lo que voy a hacer, es multiplicar esta de aquí
por 3... por 3,
¿y qué me queda?
Bueno, 3 por "2x" es lo mismo que "6x", después
tengo menos "y" por 3, es lo mismo que "-3y",
perfecto, justo lo que quería y 3 por 14,
3 por 14 es lo mismo que 30 más 12,
que es 42, 30 más 12 es 42, y entonces
"6x" menos "3y" es lo mismo que 42.
Perfecto y vamos a hacer el método de suma y resta,
así que vamos a sumar estas dos ecuaciones.
Vamos a sumar de un lado y del otro lado,
¿y qué me queda?
Bueno, del lado izquierdo, "-6x" más "6x",
estos dos se van y entonces me queda 0,
"3y" menos "3y", estos dos se van y entonces también
me quedan 0 y después tengo -42 más 42
y esto también se va y esto es igual a 0,
es decir que 0 es igual a 0
y es justo en el momento en el que tú me vas a decir que estamos hablando de un sistema dependiente,
éste es la definición de un sistema dependiente,
¿que quería decir eso?
pues ahorita lo vamos a recordar,
pero antes que nada déjame escribir
que justo esto es un sistema dependiente,
así que, bueno, mi solución de estas
dos ecuaciones es un sistema dependiente
y por lo tanto tenemos una infinidad
de soluciones...
una infinidad de soluciones,
¿y por qué es eso?
y es que si a esta ecuación que tengo aquí
la multiplico por -1, pues llego a la de aquí arriba,
es decir, "-6x" más "3y" igual a -42,
"-6x" más "3y" igual a -42,
¿y esto por qué?
porque bueno, si yo agarro esta ecuación
de arriba y la multiplico entonces por -3,
¿pues a qué crees que voy a llegar?
A la misma ecuación de abajo, esto es justo
lo que me decía un sistema dependiente,
si yo puedo hacer que una de las ecuaciones se
vea igual a la otra multiplicando por una
constante exactamente igual y entonces bueno,
ya que tengo esta ecuación,
vamos a ponerla en su forma pendiente ordenada al origen, "2x" menos "y" igual a 14,
otra vez, "2x" menos "y" igual a 14 y ahora lo que voy a
hacer es restar de ambos lados de la ecuación,
"2x" entonces menos "2x",
menos "2x" y entonces estos dos se van
y me queda que "-y" es igual a "-2x" más 14,
pero tengo a "-y", entonces para convertirla en positivo,
lo que voy a hacer multiplicar por -1 ó dicho de otra
manera, pasar el signo y cambiarle a todos el signo,
"y" es igual a "2x" menos 14.
Y ahora si, vamos a graficar para entender
mucho mejor que es lo que está pasando,
"y", este es el eje de las "y",
este es el eje de las "x" y tengo primero
una ordenada al origen de -14, es decir que mi intersección con el eje de las "y" es en el punto 0, -14
y tengo una pendiente de "2x", por lo tanto es una pendiente positiva y mi recta se ve más o menos así,
y ahora lo que quiero que veas es que no es necesario graficar esta otra recta,
porque si graficáramos esta otra recta,
¿qué crees?
me saldría la misma recta, porque es justo
lo que te dice un sistema dependiente,
estamos hablando dos veces de la misma recta,
por eso tenemos una infinidad de soluciones,
porque todos los puntos de una recta los comparte
la otra recta, es decir, que tenemos la misma recta
y esto es lo mismo que te dice un sistema
dependiente, también había otro tipo de
sistemas y vamos a recordar un poco todos
los demás sistemas.
Y después teníamos algo de la forma 0 igual a 1
y cuando teníamos algo de la forma 0 igual a 1,
o sea, 0 igual a una constante era un sistema inconsistente, un sistema inconsistente te decía,
pues que estas dos rectas nunca se intersectaban,
es decir que aquí tenemos la misma recta,
la misma línea,
mientras que aquí hablábamos de rectas paralelas,
cuando tenemos rectas paralelas
pues nunca se intersectan
y por lo tanto teníamos
un sistema inconsistente
y bueno, también teníamos los
otros sistemas que eran los sistemas
bien padres porque teníamos una solución
y una única solución, por ejemplo éste,
"x" igual a 1, "y" igual a 2 y este es un sistema completamente independiente,
porque curiosamente aquí tenemos dos rectas
y las dos rectas se intersectan en un solo punto,
es un sistema consistente,
pero bueno, entonces en este problema podemos
concluir que tenemos la misma línea
y por lo tanto pues tenemos
una infinidad de soluciones
porque estas dos ecuaciones
hablan de la misma recta.